après service après-vente photo au jour
les a enfin saisi non mais non mon coin
on et masques blancs et jaunes yeux
bruns atteignant service après-vente
bonjour au heat thémistocle tous les
rôles car oui le suppositoire
oui mais un suppositoire péruvien
évidemment service après-vente bonjour
huot bill haas c'est la route chaud non
je plaisante c'est tata suzanne série
comment tu vas me tâte a battu chez avec
le confinement tout ça ça a été chaud
bras sûrement t'as pas de fièvre
non ah bon mais tonton il a essayé de me
paie sur lui l'été chaud chaud chaud
alors ohlala ah ouais mais t'inquiète
pas je les calmer bah comme ça coulon
les parties enfin dans la partie tu sais
depuis l'opération il en a qu'une ça
mais ça vraiment bonjour j'ai mis une
casquette pour quoi faire
bon pour faire jeune de la tintin jamie
une casquette
service après-vente bonjour bonjour on
reconnaissait non c'est moi c'est moi
qui dit la cour vide que ça que j'avais
dû aux telcos vie non c'est la candidate
à chiottes
on va se tromper la quasi c'est moi
j'espère que neuf personnes à hawaï
c'est moi c'est quoi tes l'a connu ça
les apparences bonjour oui bonjour
monsieur je viens de lire une étude
comme quoi 46% des français faisais
l'amour trois fois par semaine
ouais je vais ça passait aussi à oui
mais alors qui a répondu à cette étude
excusez moi vous avez répondu voit cette
étude
voilà moi non plus a donc cette étude
est fausse ah voilà ça fait pas 46% des
français donc le français ta gueule
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire oui
mais seulement
oui mais je vois pas le rapport vous
êtes des chats j'en ai 4 mais ce n'est
pas le propos
c'est parce que je plonge au service
après-vente bonjour bonjour je vous
appelle camp gbagbo là les gens qui
arrêtent pas de critiquer tout le temps
qui permette critiqué ouais donner un
avis sur tout voie sèche pas d'accord
j'aime pour manger c'est un sport bien
ouais tu fais ça pour que les tic comme
ça est ce que moi je rappelle pour me
plaindre et quelque chose c'est suivre
non non c'est vrai vous êtes très
musique
ben ouais ça fait simplement bonjour
vous vous reconnaissez
oui guillaume gallienne
service après-vente bonjour c'est le
guillaume ses locaux et commence à
varrault cour a compliqué je sors des
mois des mois dans le faire parce que
j'ai j'ai quelqu'un un entourage de moi
qui a rattrapé le coc vie pour qu'il
devienne un chemin et que ma [ __ ]
c'est ma [ __ ] n a été qu à contacter
cette fois contact ou le temps qu'un
contact cas contacts je la fais des
pistes est tu sais les cotons-tiges
j'aimais le coton tige à positive
amer et positive mavic toi et lui et
limoges toi ne tousse pas moins d'elle
heureusement la distance est respectée
tu vois avec ma [ __ ]
comme elle est longue ça laisse à
prévoir bonjour bonjour vous me
reconnaissez c'est moi super connard
c'est moi qui dis toujours à bâle à la
place de beaune tu vois je renvoie alors
je vous souhaite une bonne journée je
vous souhaite à habiliter à voilà tu es
beau tu es beau gros coup ci par connor
sur moi service après-vente bonjour
baudu d'où tu viens plus aujourd'hui
ben non mais aussi ex cosider tout un
désespoir hier justement on a fait une
soirée qu'ovide a pas je peux dire qu'on
a mis du gel ou ça glisse et ça glisse
et où ou sa glisse et bien service
après-vente bonjour oui bonjour j'ai
appris que joe biden avait deux bergers
allemands
oui tout à fait charm paye ma job ça
veut dire je champions major moi j'en ai
qu'un il s'appelle les kane ça veut dire
les ché c'est à dire bonjour week-end
coûte en toc
ouf ouf service après-vente bonjour non
mais retirer votre base parce que
j'entends rien no - tableau comme on
veut qu'on peut pas lutter mais non
désolé ça je valide pas voilà non
[Musique]